shelby foote on the battle at gettysburg
and his book stars and their courses
this lasts about an hour
shelby foote author of stars and their
courses the gettysburg campaign where
did you get that title it comes from the
bible
the stars and their courses fought
against cicero
when deborah whoever was drove this
tent peg in his temple
freeing the jewish people from his
tyrant
she explained that he had been led into
this terrible tragedy that happened to
him by the stars in other words
fate had brought him there and the title
ties in with robert e lee being led into
defeat of pickett's charge by success
after success after success until
finally
uh
fate decided to hammer him down and they
did pick its charge
gettysburg was fought when
it was fought on three days of the first
second and third of july what year 1863
almost in the middle of the
war and
this is called the modern library of the
world's best books right why did you
decide
to do this book i mean is this the only
one you've done in this series yes it's
the only one in that series i'm on the
advisory board of the modern library and
they asked me what of mine i'd like to
have there and this is a chapter from my
three-volume civil war narrative and it
is a central chapter of the central
volume so it's sort of if i might say so
the capstone of the arch of that whole
narrative of the war
and why did you want to pick that
it uh it is more a complete story in
itself than any other section this
narrative is woven in and out of other
things but this chapter better than any
other that i know of tends to stand by
itself and could be a book of its own
if someone could someone buy this book
and not have read your others and
be comfortable reading this i think so
it's one of the few instances of an
excerpt of 90 000 or so words that you
could do that with out of that narrative
over what span of time did you write
your three volume set
i began it in 1954
under a contract with bennett surf at
random house for a short history of the
civil war
and i sat down to outline this short
history and saw that i would be simply
writing a summary and wouldn't be
interested in doing it so i wrote and
told them
at random that i'd be willing to go
whole hog spread eagle on the thing
three volumes
and there was some hesitation i presume
but in about a week i got word to go
ahead and i went ahead for the next 20
years
i finished it in uh
74. i began it in the spring of 54 and
finished in the spring of 74.
and i did not do anything else during
that whole time of any import i didn't
write a novel i didn't do any of those
things just worked on the wall where
were you living in 1954 i was living in
memphis i had just moved there from my
home about 150 miles down river in
greenville mississippi in the
mississippi delta there and i moved up
to memphis and one of the reasons i
accepted this
job offer the right civil war thing was
that
i just finished five novels
and they were more or less related to
each other and i was looking forward to
writing another set of five but i
thought it might be nice to take some
sort of vacation to break the time
between the two of them and i was going
to spend this year or maybe a year and a
half writing this this
civil war piece and the next thing you
knew i was ended up to my neck and happy
the whole time
i have a strong belief that
novelists have a great deal to teach
historians
about plotting about character drawing
about other things especially the
concern about learning to be a good
writer which many historians don't
bother to do
and
i was happy the whole time i never felt
really different right in the history
from what i'd felt writing novels
the
11 part series i think it's 11. correct
me if i'm wrong on the civil war on
public television the burn series
your face is on there a lot right how
many hours did they tape it was kind of
strange
i had
two sessions at my house with with ken
and his crew
and i took them to shiloh
and i took them to vicksburg and we did
a little filming at shiloh and a little
at vicksburg but most of it was done
right there in the sitting room at my
house
and i think he had maybe four hours of
tape
out of which he took what he wanted how
has that changed your
public uh
pursue well i mean that that's what it
did change is my public thing it uh it
vaulted me into the public detention
which had uh been miniscu before that
and uh i had all kind of reactions to
that happening
but
it sold books that's a glorious thing
about it the the war
had come out it
stayed in hardcover but it also came out
in vintage which is a soft back
subsidiary around them and uh
it took off like a skyrocket after this
television program up till that program
do you know how many copies were sold it
sold rather well it it did well it got
good reviews for all three volumes and
was selling well but it um it really
took off after the television any idea
how many
uh
volume one is in its 21st edition now i
think it's uh it's a huge number would
that mean hundreds of thousands of books
yes for the three volumes
so what what's happened to you since
you've been seen by so many people
uh
i i
i get this strange star quality reaction
from people which i find rather
unpleasant really
crossing an airport or
going somewhere to dinner or something
there are people who come over and say
how much they enjoyed the war
i i haven't yet had anyone come up to me
and take the trouble and say they didn't
enjoy it
but they do tend to come over and say
how do you deal with it
i tell them that i'm glad to hear it uh
and one reason i'm so glad to hear it
aside from personal vanity is
i'm always pleased to know that i might
have had something to do with people
beginning to understand the american
civil war which i think is enormously
important for every american citizen
somebody told me that you didn't like to
sign books
i don't sign books except for close
friends
and i do it for two reasons one is i
think it makes it mean something that
way when you do sign it and the other is
i'm saving myself and awful lot of other
people a lot of trouble not fooling
around that autographing business i
think it's ridiculous when did you
decide to do this early on way back when
i was writing first first novel i did it
that way do you find people get mad at
you because you won't do it
occasionally somebody gets mad but
mostly when i tell them why
they say i understand that yes that's
right they even approve of it
yeah
when did you first get interested in the
civil war
any
deep south boy anyhow and probably all
southern boys who knows
they've been familiar with the civil war
as a sort of thing in their conscience
going back
i honestly believe
that it's in all our subconscious
this country was into its adolescence at
the time of the civil war it really was
it hadn't formulated itself really as an
adult nation
and the civil war did that and like all
traumatic experiences that you might
have had in your adolescence it stays
with you the rest of your life
certainly in your subconscious most
likely in your conscience too
and i think the civil war had the nature
of that kind of experience for the
country
we now recognize anybody's looked into
it at all
realizes that it truly is the
outstanding
event in american history insofar as
making us what we are the kind of
country we are emerged from the civil
war not from the revolution revolution
provided us with the constitution it got
broke us loose from england made us free
made us men but the civil war really
defined us
it uh it said what we were going to be
and said well we're not going to be
it drifted away from the southern mostly
virginia influence up into the new
england and middle western influence and
we became
that kind of nation instead of the other
kind of nation
what would have happened if stephen
douglas had won the presidency in 1860 i
i can't help but think i i usually don't
like what-ifs and
and so on but
i think that if if douglas had been
elected it simply would have postponed
the problem i think the problem was
there
uh sue had called an irrepressible
conflict and i think he was there and i
think it would have been there
while douglas was there or certainly
after douglas left
all these splits were going on the wigs
were dissolving or had dissolved
there were issues that were so
bitter between the abolitionists in new
england and the fire eaters in south
carolina and various other places in the
south
i'm almost willing to believe
that with all our genius for compromise
there still wasn't any way to settle
this thing except by fighting
the most regretful thing is that the
thing went on for four years was an
incredible savagery
uh that's the great shame there was
bound to be a fight
but for it to be the fight that it was
with
literally more than a million american
casualties is uh
that that need not have been something
should have stopped it before that
how many men fought on the
union side and how many on the there's a
there's a good deal of
argument about that
i've forgotten the exact figures uh
there
probably were a million and a half
union and possibly as many as 80 80
800 000 confederates maybe those figures
will hold how many died
the death total about 650
000
it might two things might bring home to
you how savage it was uh
all the american wars combined now this
is somewhat unfair because i'm only
talking about american casualties and
those other wars
i'm not including the foreign casualties
but
more americans were casualties in the
american civil war than in all the wars
we've been engaged in the revolution the
war of 1812 the mexican war all rolled
in together not as many casualties
as there were
at shiloh
the first great battle of the war lasted
two days it was 25 000 cashless there
and that's the total cashes of all the
american wars up to there
what was greenville mississippi like
greenville mississippi just barely
existed at the time of the civil war
where i'm from is called the mississippi
yazoo alluvial delta
and it was only settled along the yazoo
and the mississippi the whole interior
was one great swamp filled with
alligators and moccasins and it wasn't
until after the civil war they put the
railroad in and could get the trees out
and then dig the drainage dishes and it
became habitable
but greenville was shelled during the
war it was a little town on the river
and it was shelled as a diversion to
grants attack on vicksburg you were born
in 1916 1916 where what were your
parents like what did they do
my father came from a
long line of
illustrious mississippians uh
his grandfather my great-grandfather
commanded an oxygenated cavalry at
shiloh
and
his father
was a planter there in the delta
uh and he expected to live a life of
ease mainly involving
dice shooting and cards and whiskey and
flying around and his own father
short-circuited that by put pushing his
fortune across polka tape and lost the
plantation
so my father
had just married my mother and scarce
knew what he was going to do with
himself and her father got him a job as
a shipping clerk at armored company
there in greenville
and in the next six years
somehow or another he he changed
everything about himself and uh wound up
managing armor branches in
pensacola jackson
and it's just been transferred to mobile
where he was the
head man in the southern region and he
died of septicemia for my operation on
his nose i was just short of six years
old
so i was uh
i often look back on it uh if he had
lived
it's pretty clear he would have wound up
in chicago with almond company and i'd
have been a chicago kid
going to prep schools and living in some
suburbs and i consider that a great
deliverance
i'm sorry i had to sacrifice my father
to do it but uh
it's it's strange what what accidental
things like septicemia can do to
people's lives do you remember him at
all i do
it's a good test for me or how bad
people generally can remember i remember
very almost clear snapshots when i was
like four and five
uh but
i'll tell you a strange thing about
memory uh it fades i'm 77 now
your memory fades and i will remember my
father very clearly and then it'll fade
and then about another five years when
it's almost faded out of sight i'll have
a very vivid dream of him and the
memories back fresh again in my
conscience
that's a strange phenomenon to me
that's your mom
my mother
never remarried
and
i was an only child
and uh her
her devotion to me
uh
meant so much to me because i was a kid
who stayed in trouble all the time i was
editing the high school paper and
dedicated myself to giving the principal
a hard time and when it came time for me
to go to college
i applied to chapel hill for admission
and
received a letter back saying uh
we're sorry there's no place for you
here the principal had taken the trouble
to write them a letter saying do not let
this boy in your school under any
circumstance
but i got in the car and drove up there
and got in line for registration when i
reached the desk they looked in the file
and said they told you not to come and i
said
i know you did but i didn't think you
meant it
now this is 1935 there were empty rooms
and dormitories and everything else and
they said all right since you're here
so so i went schooling why did the
principal feel that strong because i've
been giving him a hard time as edited to
the high school paper
how did you get interested in even
writing
that's always hard for a writer to say
um
i'm sure my interest began and an
interest in reading
which
then was translated into an interest in
writing how did this fellow do this
i can remember
in a sunday school prize or something
when i was about 11 years old
i won a copy of david copperfield
up that time i'd read
the bobsy twins and then tom swift and
the rover boys
and tarzan
but since i got this as a prize i
decided i should read it
and i found a world that was realer than
the world i lived in unlike these
tarzans and other books
this was a whole other world and
it was a world of art i couldn't have
defined it as that but one thing i knew
david
copperfield better than anybody i knew
in the real world including myself
and i said my god to myself
this is a whole world i didn't then read
all of dickens or start becoming a
serious reader until three or four years
later but i remember vividly having that
reaction to that book david copperfield
i think most writers probably have that
experience
what year did you get out of uh college
i only went two years uh
the war was heading up uh hitler was on
the rampage and uh
i knew we were going to get in and i
wanted us to get in it so i came home
to spend the year that was left
getting to know my homeland before i got
my head blown off in the war
and
then i joined the mississippi national
guard when hitler went into poland this
was by way of telling me he couldn't get
away couldn't get away with that
and the guard mobilized in november 1940
we went down to camp blanding and began
basic training
did you go overseas yeah i went to um
office candidate school at fort sill
oklahoma
in i think it was january 42 right after
pearl harbor
and finished there
came back to camp shelby mississippi and
was carried out to
camp bowie texas and brownwood near
dallas and fort worth
and then went overseas and joined the
fifth division
which had been in iceland for
since way before pearl harbor
and uh
ran crossways of a
colonel on the staff there who's well
known for somebody you should not get
crossways of
and uh he lay for me and finally got me
on falsifying a government document uh
it was
a rule that you could not use
a vehicle
for recreation
beyond a distance of 50 miles and we
were 54 miles from belfast so it was a
common practice among us right 50 miles
our battalion was outside that 50-mile
radio
and
that was the charge of falsifying the
government document and i was
court-martialed sent home
i stayed home i worked on a local desk
at associated press for about six months
and i couldn't take it any longer and
went down joined the marine corps
and i was in the marine corps for a year
and they dropped the bomb and the thing
was over and i came on home
the marines were funny about that they
said
my fellow marines went through boot camp
parasite and everything i haven't been a
captain in the army
and they said you used to be a captain
in the army you might make a pretty good
marine if you work at it at all
i enjoyed it i like the marines
so if i figure right in 1954 you were
about 37 38 years old when you started
writing about the civil war right when
you went
to europe and you were in the marines
and in the army did you know anything
about the civil war then
yes i carried with me
uh
in my baggage i carried gfr henderson
stonewall jackson
i had
freeman's r e lee with me as often as i
could lug it around
and i spent my spare time even then
figuring out what happened during the
seven days and drawing maps and things
it always fascinated me
you say in this uh
book for the modern library at one point
that when robert e lee was
up north people would stop him from the
north and get his autograph right how
come
there was an uh a general uh admiration
for lee
it's curious in the civil war
the men who were most hated were not
very dangerous men they were men like
butler
and uh
god knows who you'd name on the southern
side that they hated so much they were
not much killers the real killers like
grant lee were enormously admired by the
opposite side there's very something
very strange about that
but it's uh it it is strange
when you started really thinking about
writing
when you were 37 or so did had you been
to a lot of civil war sites yes it was a
sort of hobby of mine i went but i was
going back and forth in new york three
or four times a year driving in those
days up us 11 through the shenandoah
valley and all that and i would stop at
battlefields all along and go out of my
way to go to them just to see what they
felt like
invest in battlefields it's very
important that you go
at the same time a year if possible on
the very anniversary of the battle
because for places so different other
times a year to understand the battle
shiloh
if you went there when it was fought in
early april you would see what it was
like if you went there in february or
later on in july it'd be a different
field you wouldn't understand the way uh
the new growth of leaves choked
everything in so nobody knew what
direction north south east or west was
so you get that thing and you get the
weather you get the soil you get the
coloration of things get the true feel
of it
you said earlier that the civil war
defined what we were going to be right
but we're not going to be right
what are we
well
the civil war
uh
included emancipation
and it was immediately followed by true
emancipation i mean the constitution
freed slaves not just those who win
rebel hands is lincoln's proclamation
claim would you before you ever define
the word emancipation what does it mean
emancipation means a setting free of
people who are in slavery uh lincoln's
emancipation proclamation did not free
anybody
what it did was it declared that all
slaves
not then in territory occupied by the
union
would be free as of january 1st
meaning
if i can reach out and touch you you're
not free
if you're beyond my reach you're free
well they didn't immediately say i am
free and married somewhere they couldn't
um but the real emancipation
constitutional amendment freed slaves
freed all the slaves
and slavery is a a
huge stain on us we all carry it i carry
it deep in my bones the
the consequences of slavery
but emancipation
comes pretty close to being as heavy as
sin
they told
what is it six seventh out seven million
people uh you are now free hit the road
and there was the friedman's bureau
which was a sort of joke there were
people down here exploiting them uh
three quarters of them couldn't read or
write had no job no hope of a job no way
of learning a job even and they drifted
back into this uh
pennant situation under sharecropping
which was about all they could do
and uh to this day
uh we are paying and they are paying for
this kind of treatment the emancipation
i don't mean it should have been a
gradual emancipation i mean there should
have been true preparation to get these
people ready for living
uh
a kind of life they were free and should
have been free all along but they were
not prepared for living in the world
they'd lived in and living on the
conditions of slavery which uh uh kept
them from living in the world
you say also to find what we're not what
we were not gonna be and what does that
mean it means the loss of the so-called
southern virtues some of which are very
real uh
man's
word is his bond uh
the business of not insulting each other
with impunity
some of these things are very small but
they're way larger than the human scale
you moved to memphis which is in the
south right why did you choose to leave
greenville to go to memphis what was the
real reason i never left home when i
came to memphis memphis is the capital
of the mississippi delta even though
it's in tennessee it's the city if
you're in the south delta you go to new
orleans if you're anywhere above the
middle delta you go to memphis uh i
don't think there's been a season of my
life that i hadn't been in memphis with
my mother or one of my aunts and uncles
up there shopping and everything people
went up there for everything
men to buy
guns and shoes and things and women to
buy clothes
it's uh it's just
this was before they were malls and
designer
dealers with a designer clothes in small
towns so excursions to memphis were
frequent and for shopping purposes you
have a family
i was
just my mother and i all the time until
right after the war i was married got
divorced
and then remarried again after i moved
to memphis
i've been married
now for
36 years i think children
one child son 32 years old what's he
doing
he's a photographer and uh getting to be
a good one
did did he take any of the photos of you
that we see ever no he takes photographs
from me but
for some reason another that that that
brand of nepotism i haven't been
involved with where was this photo taken
that was taken at home but it was done
by a photographer from denver his name
is larry shirkey
and that's a a
cut from a larger photograph do you
purposely have all your photos taken
with this without a smile
i think that i do uh
i share that with abraham lincoln
there's only one photograph of lincoln
that has a little bit of a ghost of a
smile and that's the last one the one
was taken just shortly before the
assassination and when he knew the war
was one because if you go back and look
at your three volume series there are
different pictures on them right at that
age and and when did you did you
consciously decide to have always a
serious look
i don't think so i i think it probably
a battery of psychiatrists could figure
it out i think but
no not not consciously for one thing i
don't like having a picture made and
that's one reason
i'm frowning saying i don't like this i
don't like this experience
when did you write your first novel
i wrote my first novel
i said i left school to come home and
wait for the water to start i wrote the
first draft of my first novel during
that period while i was waiting for the
war to start in 1939 and 40.
and
then when i came back from war in 45
i sat down and revised it and it still
was my first novel it was published by
dial
in 1949. what was it it was called
tournament and it's a story about a
planter in the mississippi delta about
his rise and fall
very loosely
based on my grandfather's life
although he died before i was born so it
wasn't out of personal acquaintance with
him you've written how many novels
i've written six novels five before the
war and one since how many non-fiction
total books uh this is my only
non-fiction the civil war narrative
do you like one over the other
no uh
i
i suspect i like to think of myself as a
novelist because that's what i was
for most of my life and that's the way i
thought of myself and i haven't changed
uh and it pleases me when someone tells
me what they like best is my novels but
uh
no i i i
i faced the fact that i probably am more
apt to be known for writing this this
through volume history than anything
else
ed by the way since your
fame from television have your novel
sold any yes they have vintages brought
them out in softback those that were out
of print are back in print and they do
quite well
uh one of the things that in one of the
notes in one of your books i found was
that one of your favorite uh or your
favorite historian is tacitus is that
how you're pronouncing it who was he
tastus was a
a roman historian right after the
birth and death of jesus
and he
is
above all a writer
test style is just a joy to be involved
with whether in their original latin
which i can barely stumble through or in
a decent translation it's very hard to
get a good translation of testis a man
named broad rip did pretty good
and uh there's something about him he
writes about how i play scoundrels for
the most part
and he takes that roman empire apart
some historian said about
i guess was claudius uh
that he um was a successful emperor
hard-working everything else and then
alas he fell upon the pen of tasks
which always tickled me as rule but i
like testis very much the other
historians i like a lot
when were you introduced
to tesla's
probably during high school probably was
when i first encountered i took latin in
high school we didn't have testosterone
tests it's too hard to read
you do season and then finally virgil
but you don't get to test this until you
go on from there and also you mentioned
the peloponnesian wars right thursdays
are there any is there any relationship
between what you read there and what you
have found about the civil war yes a
great deal uh i'll tell you something
interesting stylistically
there's a strong belief
i think it's utterly true
that given and writing the decline fall
was strongly influenced by fielding's
tom jones
there's also a strong belief that
thucydides history of the peloponnation
was strongly influenced by his reading
of aeschylus and sophocles
i believe that the artists are out front
and have a great deal to teach
historians about a good writing and
dramatic composition which i consider
the best history to be and
aristotle
said uh in criticizing great drama
that you learn
first you learn how to write well a good
sophomore high school can do a
surprisingly good description of a
sunset then you learn to draw characters
that can stand up and cast a shadow and
the last thing you learn to do is plot
that's the
skill that comes last if it comes at all
and that is where i think historians
neglect
a huge advantage i think history has a
plot you don't make it up you discover
it it's there
oscar wildset talks about life imitating
art
i have noticed that when a man dies no
matter at what age or by what cause his
life then has a beginning in the middle
and an end
and sometimes his death explains his
youth
good friends of mine who were killed in
the war
spent their youth exactly as if they
knew they're going to be killed
overplayed
it's a it's a very strange business but
that's art taking over
insisting on giving a thing form when it
seems to be formless
and i think that when you supply that
form and i mind you i'm not talking
about super pose superimposing i
discover the form
it makes that a very exciting reading
experience
uh if you pick up your civil war
series or this book
[Music]
you just well there's actually in this
book there's a little introduction uh
about shelby foot tells us about you but
your other books you just start right
right off so does the narrative there's
no preface saying i hold my debts to
this and that you know that all comes at
the end it starts
and in the uh in the full narrative the
sections i never called books chapters
chapters in my novels but in the history
i was careful to call it chapter one
chapter two emphasizing its uh kinship
to the novel
there are no footnotes and no
bibliography
the subject
after 100 years
is well enough known not to need
footnotes uh the civil war footnotes are
extremely useful to other historians and
i was writing for historians enjoyment
and i hope instruction but mainly i did
not want to interrupt this narrative
with this bunch of footnotes down at the
bottom of the page where your eye leaves
the story every now and then it lands
down at the footnote uh i thought that
the footnotes
would cost me more
artistically than they would gain me in
academic respect
who's ralph newman ralph newman is a
civil war enthusiast from chicago
and one of the leading
persons to make the civil war into the
american consciousness through a thing
he had called the american lincoln book
shop there in chicago he was one of the
founders of the civil war roundtable in
chicago which i think was the first of
the round tables they during this long
before this period of the huge
popularity civil war
were working away at it and doing very
interesting stuff rent bring it up you
also mentioned one of your books your
comments at the end that he came out
with a bibliography that took
you didn't have to do it he and his
friend pete long published a separate
bibliography uh that covers everything
and i said if you want to know where i
got my books go to go to go to newman's
bibliography that's where i got it 350
books in the civil war
about that number was the working
library i had near my in my desk at all
times i worked from printed sources
entirely i did not get into the archives
and dig around among
manuscripts have you read all those
books yes i had i read them and read
them with pleasure most of them
one of the other things i noticed in
reading this is that you'll just start
with a name i mean there's not an
explanation of where this person comes
from and all right what i do is i work
in development i don't stop the story to
tell you who somebody was
i
release things about his life as the
story goes along i've got a long way to
go you see i've got a million and a half
words there and i take my time
uh you don't find where lee courted his
wife until the battle of fredericksburg
he's looking through his binoculars
across the rappahannock at an oak tree
in the yard of a house over there and he
that's where he courted his wife um and
it picks these pieces up as you go along
until finally i hope you get to know
these people the way you do get to know
people in real life find out little by
little about them instead of just
three pages of biography where do you
where have you written all these books
physically
i wrote the first volume
on the exact western city limits of
memphis because it's on the bluff
overlooking the mississippi river
the second volume was written on the
eastern limits of memphis which yates
road was then the eastern limits of that
and the third volume was written where i
live now right in the geographical
center of memphis all three volumes were
written
every line of them there in memphis in a
house or a office or in a house
i've always
always worked in a room
uh
where i usually sleep
so that i sleep near my desk and the
typewriter's over here
and uh
there's something about it when i go
somewhere else like in the summer go
down on the coast or something i i can't
work away from home i'd have to stay
there for two weeks before i could start
writing
i'm not like say d.h lawrence who could
write anywhere
and in fact never had a home
but uh to me it's a it's a very
deliberate thing five or six hundred
words is a good day for me i write with
a dip pen which causes all kind of
problems everything from finding
blotters to pinpoints
uh but it makes me take my time and it
gives me a real feeling of satisfaction
and i'm getting where i'm going what's a
dip pen
it's the kind you see in post offices
all the time when you were a boy
i would love to find one of those ink
wells they had in post offices they had
a spring in them when you pressed down
it would wet the pinpoint and when you
lift it out it would close it again so
the ink didn't evaporate i can't find
one i'm absolutely certain right here in
washington there are five million of
them in a warehouse somewhere but i
can't find one but a dip pen uh
you have to dip it in the ink right
three or four words and dip it again and
it uh it has a real influence on the way
i write
so different not only from a typewriter
but from using a pencil or a finding pad
what do you do with it after it's
written the 500 words every day i said
it decided to dry
then uh copy it off
typewriter copy it
make a typewritten copy of it and then
read copy on that until finally the day
is over and i'm always satisfied with it
and i put it on stack make a clean copy
and put on stack
that way i don't have to engage in
something that to me is a particular
form of heartbreak which is revision i
don't do that my best friend in life for
60 years was walker percy he had exactly
the opposite he said if i knew what was
going to happen next i wouldn't be able
to write
i wouldn't be interested in writing if i
knew what was going to happen i'm the
other way
and so you're never edited
no there's there's no no real need i may
take out a comma or put in a hand or
something but very minor stuff you know
you have this arrangement with your
publisher yeah
my editor at random house
for
35 years now is has been bob loomis
uh he's a good editor and uh our
arrangement is that uh
he will encourage me he will do
everything in the world and make me feel
about that i'm doing well and this and
that and the other but he doesn't mess
with my doesn't mess with the text you
know many authors that have this kind of
arrangement
uh
william faulkner had it
i've seen a fault in the proof
somebody presumed to read the galley
proofs and make a correction of
something the falcon scratches out the
next time he got down to one he saw
another correction mark and he wrote god
damn it legally alone
that's the way i felt about it too
how long does it take you to write the
500 600 words a day
a long time most writers i know
work all morning and then free in the
afternoon evening some few i know work
at night
very few riders i know work over four or
five hours a day which is a long day for
a writer i work in the morning three or
four hours and then go back in the
afternoon work three or four hours
it's because i'm a slow writer i have to
do that much to mount
i write about a hundred thousand words a
year
year and year out
do you keep all of these facts and
figures in your head
mostly in my head uh
particular quotations that i want to be
sure to keep up with i'll write on a
piece of paper and stick on a
a piece of beaver board that's in front
of my desk so i won't forget to get it
but mostly i carry this in my head but
by way of preparation for this i did
something that i think anybody would
find useful i got large cardboard
posters and drew columns down it
and then
put the year 61 2345
and i'd had diplomacy military
political and other things and so that
at a glance i could tell what was going
on at that particular time and that's
where the plotting came in so that you
weave the diplomatic situation in the
political situation and the military
situation all into a narrative
we
hesitate to ask this because
i'm not sure which way you'd go but
because you might not even like the
question but who are your favorites
who are your favorite characters
after writing all these words about the
civil war you mean civil war characters
yes
uh
it's easy to state who your favorites
are because there are many people's
favorite robert e lee
u.s grant stonewall jackson tecumseh
chairman
but i have some favorites that are
grievously neglected
one of them is an arkansas general named
pat claben patrick ronyan cleban
from arkansas and he probably was the
best division commander on either side
and in his day he was killed at franklin
about a year before the end of the war
but in his day he was called the
stonewall jackson of the west and well
known and adored by his men
and he's been largely forgotten today
he's buried right there at hell now
where crawley's ridge comes to the
mississippi
and i'm very fond of clayman and uh
i got the same reaction as clavin's
death that his men got i was greatly
saddened
to lose him
you get you get a great fondness for
these people or a severe dislike for
them and if you have a dislike for them
uh you lean over backward hoping not to
let it show
uh i'm sure it does
this is about this particular book is in
this modern library series it sells for
1350 i think right
what is this syria and you're on this
board yeah what is it well uh
i'm surprised you would ask because to
me
being as old as i am the modern library
was what i grew up with it was my
introduction to everybody gertrude stein
william faulkner everybody was in the
modern library and that's where you went
if you wanted to keep up with that plus
the classics
the
we've talked about tacitus and
thucydides i read them in the modern
library
uh
times being what they were but they were
95 cents a copy in those days
not nearly as well printed or as
handsomely bound as now but uh
95 cents you could get
all of the thucydides
well ask them because it seems like
there's a new something new going on
because right
you see these now in a lot more
bookstores right
new uh
you know
covers right and what what what is
happening and you're on the board what's
the the name of the
maya angelou and
daniel borsten and uh christopher surf
by the way is he related to minutes he's
been his son
and
shelby footson here and and uh bartend
gregorian from brown university
used to run the new york library and
edmond morris the biographer of
ronald reagan and theodore roosevelt
arthur schlesinger and william starman
and gore vidal right what do you all do
we meet and each has books that he would
like to see in it and we all decide
whether they should be done the head of
it is a young woman named susan decessor
who is an excellent editor
and uh we we decide uh what should be in
there and sometimes decide what should
not and it's it's a growing list and a
good one all the old titles are
available too the chaucer for instance
is coming out in a month or so come on
beautiful book random house
it is the random house what uh
well knife has lately bought every man's
library which i'm sure you remember
many publishing houses have
have these things it's a combination of
classics
uh ancient classics and sort of modern
classics too
um when i was growing up i remember
seeing bennett surf on television
i don't remember what the show was like
what's my line or something like yeah
watch my line was that it yeah is he
still alive no ben has been dead about
seven or eight years now
he uh he was a very likable man and not
many people realized because he was such
a pun stun and so forth what a good
editor he was he shook up the the
whole publishing business in new york
with random house he started it on a
shoestring and drove it right to the top
he got proust he's the one who got hold
of proof he got ulysses joyce's ulysses
it was bennett sir if he was who did
that he did a lot of things
did
from the books that you've written about
the civil war and from your appearance
on the civil war series have you learned
anything new about the united states and
the people's reaction to it
uh
the
the biggest change i've seen
is in
the the racial problem the blacks
and some of it i regret very much
quite the opposite
of the jews in the case of the holocaust
the blacks seem not to want to be
reminded of history seem not to want to
in this disney project it was announced
we will show you what it was like to be
a slave but when a great outcry went up
we don't want to see that kind of thing
almost the opposite of the jews having
holocaust museums and all kinds of
things
uh i regret that uh
i i think they ought to celebrate their
past the same way the jews did about
bondage in egypt they're not ashamed of
it they say we came out of it we we
we conquered it and i wish there were
more of that
the civil war
there's a great compromise as it's
called
it consists of
southerners
admitting
freely that it's probably best that the
union wasn't divided
and the north admits rather freely that
the south fought bravely for a cause in
which it believed and that is a great
compromise and we live with that and
that works for us
we are now able to look at the war with
some coolness which we couldn't do
before now and incidentally i very much
doubt whether a history such as mine
could have been written
much before
a hundred years it elapsed it took all
that time for things to cool down
when i was a
a grade school boy in mississippi
i knew obscene dog grill about abraham
lincoln
left over from my parents and
grandparents
yankees were despised uh when one of
them was so unfortunate as to move to
greenville mississippi he was he was
despised uh all that stopped all that's
over now
and
the the great compromise obtains
and i wish
my black friends could do the same thing
the illinois senator who
didn't want the daughters of the
confederacy in richmond to have a
confederate symbol not the battle flag
just a confederate symbol on their
stationary got her fellow senators to
disallow it
i do not understand that that's a
violation of the compromise for example
and it's a an arousal of bitterness but
she
along with a great many others do not
want to be reminded
she has every right to want to hide from
history if she wants to but it seems to
me she's trying to hide history from us
and that's a mistake
what do you think of abraham lincoln
uh
the first word that i have for abraham
lincoln is genius
there's never been a man functioning the
way lincoln did he had never occupied
anything resembling an executive
position before he came here to be
president he knew almost nothing about
the office
uh he didn't know how it ran he didn't
know about departments like the treasury
and so forth he had done the term in
congress which familiarized with that he
was very active in politics uh the
lincoln douglas debates show that a man
knew a lot about government but the
actual executive job he learned on the
job
and he was just a miracle at it he was a
true genius
we are
covering a reenactment of the lincoln
douglas debates this summer and another
person that i want to ask you about in
that context is stephen douglas
and popular sovereignty an issue we've
discussed a lot here right um what do
you think of that idea
well uh douglas is an interesting man
because
he had a profound influence on history
if he didn't do but one thing
he ran for office
up to then
no man would run for the presidency of
the united states you couldn't say i
want to be president united states so
you i should be president united states
nobody would say a thing like that it
was uh too presumptuous
you sat back and other people said you
should be president douglas said i want
to be president i should be president uh
others talked about their theories and
everything but douglas was the first to
campaign now today they campaign like
mad and they do nothing but campaign for
two years before the election but it was
unthankable before douglas fed by the
campaign
uh douglas came south he said uh he told
his advisors we have to go south try to
swing this thing heal this brick break
it didn't succeed
do you have any sense of what impact the
lincoln-douglas debates actually had in
those days
uh i'll tell you one impact it had it
kept douglas from being president united
states and it made abraham lincoln
president united states when he asked
douglas that thing
you always have to wonder whether some
particular thing that lincoln does is
done by accident or mistake or through
this kind of genius the firing on sumter
is the case uh uh the decision to
reinforce something uh
he either thought
the south was going back down
or
he thought he was going to provoke a
civil war there wasn't anything else
that could happen from doing that so did
he blunder into it
or did he have enough foresight to see
four years later there was going to be a
re-established union that's too much to
ask him to have done that but did he
really provoke a civil war doing that
well during the douglas debate he pulls
the question to douglas where if douglas
answered yes
he would
win the election if he answered no
he would lose the presidential election
two or so years later or whatever many
years it was and he had him hoist on his
pitard there and douglas gave the answer
that won the senatorial election but
we're losing the presidential election
was the civil war inevitable
i think that it was necessary uh
i do not believe that those differences
could have been settled without
bloodshed
uh the question is
the horrendous amount of bloodshed
needed
that was not necessary that could have
been stopped at some point god knows but
there apparently what difference is so
profound
between the abolitionists of new england
and the fire eaters of south carolina
that drag the rest of the country into
this conflict that
i'm inclined to agree with sued who
called it an irrepressible conflict
uh from what you know
now and your own political philosophy if
you had a choice
and you lived back there which side
would you have been on there's
absolutely no doubt about it i'm from
mississippi i would have been on the
confederate side right all wrong i would
have fought with my people
why
because they're my people
it uh
it would have meant the end of my life
as i'd known it if i fought on the other
side it would have been a
falsification of everything i'd lived by
even if i opposed it
no matter how much i was opposed to
slavery i still would have fought for
the confederacy not for slavery but for
other things such as freedom to seize
aid from the union is there still
a difference in the way people live in
mississippi think than say the people in
illinois
much less
than my boyhood far less
in my boyhood and i'm old enough to go
back before radios be in common
you had radios in towns where there was
electricity but you remember
i mean
you must know that before rea there
wasn't any electricity in the country
some few people had delco generators for
electric lights and everything but
the name roosevelt was always roosevelt
you never heard it you see it was always
called roosevelt and it carried on down
now there's been an homogenization of of
accents and voices that
i don't speak exactly the way a new
englander does but i speak a lot closer
to it now than i used to or than my
people
nowadays do i remember breaking up a
zoology class at chapel hill
talking about earthworms
they never really say earth william it's
a kind of new orleans accent do you have
any other books that you're writing say
we're at a hundred thousand words a year
what do you write about uh i write about
the mississippi delta all those novels
are concerned with that it's my homeland
it's what i know
i don't have to do any research
it's all in my experience
i enjoyed very much uh doing the
research and getting to know these
people well enough
i felt no different uh working with
facts that i got out of documents than i
did with facts so-called that i got out
of my head they're both facts you have
to be true to them a good novelist is
the truth to his
facts as a historian is to his uh
it's true you can't
give lincoln the color eyes you want to
they were gray blue but
but there they are they're gray blue and
you deal with them you're going to write
any more nonfiction
uh
i don't think so i i don't believe i
will an occasional thing i recently
wrote
an introduction to stephen crane's red
badge of courage and rather enjoyed
doing it there's about 10 000 words or
so but uh
i'm a novelist is what i am from
anything how often are we going to see
you in the public spotlight from now on
i don't know i suspect less and less and
less and less why
it's too disruptive uh i was talking
about my work habits it also includes
working seven days a week if i stop
uh the steam goes out of the boiler and
i have spent another two days building
up a head of steam
so that stopping is very bad i'm
actually unable to work if i'm going
somewhere and doing something every 14
days or something i just wouldn't i
would never get anything done we were
talking earlier about
your work habits i want to ask you
what you're like to be around
when you're writing
i don't know because i don't allow
anybody around while i'm writing
my wife manages to live with me and my
my son and my dog
but
i like to be let alone when i'm working
i see these hollywood movies where the
man gets up in the middle of the night
and dashes off a few thousand words and
his little wife comes in to make sure
he's comfortable and everything that's
all foolishness there's never be
anything like that
in fact i'm privately convinced that
most of the really bad writing the
world's ever seen has been
done under the influence of what's
called inspiration
writing is very hard work and knowing
what you're doing the whole time
and so what kind of a stretch do you go
that you just you're in that writing
mode
a month or so then take some time off
take a week or somewhere rest up enjoy
yourself come back to it this doesn't
mean i don't spend my evenings
socializing having fun with friends go
out to dinner all that kind of thing i
do
you have a note in one of your books
that says thanks to my friends that
allowed me to spend an evening without
talking about the civil war right right
when you're not talking about the civil
war what are you talking about
talking about the latest gossip of
what's going on up the street there and
how somebody getting along here and
general politics on the national scene
it's uh
a writer's like anybody else except when
he's right
this is what the book looks like the
modern library series
and our guest has been
shelby foote author of the civil war and
six novels thank you for joining us
thank you i enjoyed being with you
shelby foote is a world war ii veteran
having served in the european theater
he's written extensively on the civil
war